[Music]
a startling discovering the west valley
leaves neighbors quite shaken
homicide detectives are investigating
after they say human remains were found
in the backyard of a desert shore's home
sasha loftis has been speaking with
those who live in the area she joins us
live with what she's learned sasha
kirsten this investigation which we're
told will lasted for about a day
just wrapped up a few moments ago police
did leave this scene
but there are tape tape marks on the
door
and the garage door is this
investigation obviously is ongoing now
i'm told the discovery was made
yesterday afternoon
police sources say they received a tip
about this home
and noticed some suspicious things
inside two neighbors then reportedly
told investigators they saw two people
digging in the backyard last week
neighbors tell me the home appeared
empty for years however
according to the clark county assessor's
website and searches on the address a
woman in her 80s owns this home
neighbors say it is really unsettling to
see something like this happen
as a fan of some horror movies and stuff
you just never expect it to happen in
real life but so
you know we just don't know you know who
who the victim was or
you know what the circumstances were but
you know we definitely
kind of keep an eye out for everybody in
the neighborhood
homicide detectives originally said this
investigation would continue
into the evening but as i mentioned
before as you can see behind me here
back out
here live the investigation has wrapped
up for now but of course
this is still ongoing now some other
neighborhood or neighbors rather that i
spoke with said
this house appeared to have been empty
for about 10 or 15 years
so no word exactly what happened here we
will of course keep you updated continue
speaking with people in this
neighborhood
and bring you the latest this evening
reporting live in las vegas sasha loftus
8 news now